les médias de masse audiovisuel ne parle
des élections qu'à proportion de
l'audience que ça peut faire dans le
public dans un paysage concurrentiel où
ils sont là ce n'est pas un secret et
c'est totalement normal dans ce dans le
système actuel
ils sont là pour faire de l'audience et
donc si en tant que média vous consacrer
un temps d'antenne assez conséquent a
parlé de choses dont beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens se foutent
vous allez perdre de l'audience c'est
aussi simple que ça je vous rappelle que
il ya un million de français qui ont
voté à l'élection de miss france en
termes de centres d'intérêt et donc ceci
pour 17 pas beaucoup c'est pas c'est
quand même pas mal en fait
alors qu'on n'en parle jamais sauf en
soir c'est quand même remarquable et
donc ceci pour dire plus haut au delà de
l'anecdote mais simplement je regarde
les chiffres en arrivant et ça me
paraissait un peu étonnant mais ceci
pour dire que les médias nous parlent de
la présidentielle parce que quand ils en
parlent ça fait de l'audience c'est que
quand ils font des débats télé entre les
candidats à la présidentielle ça fait de
l'audience et donc ça permet d'avoir à
mesure de l'audience des recettes
publicitaires c'est ça le modèle
économique d'un média et c'est pareil
pour la presse papier c'est pareil pour
la radio etc etc et donc il ne parle
quasiment pas des départementales parce
qu'en réalité nous en tant que public
consommateur de leur offre médiatique on
s'en on est trop nombreux à s'en
pareil pour les régionales elles sont
aussi des régionales est quand même
parler des réglisses en ont très peu
parlé en réalité et quand il en parle je
m'en rends compte quand on m'interroge
pour le en tant qu'analyste politique ou
commentateurs éditorialistes pour les
régionales on me posait surtout des
conseils des questions sur les
conséquences possibles des régionales en
vue de la présidentielle
et on m'a quasiment pas pareil peut
poser poser de questions les
journalistes sur les régionales pourquoi
il s'intéresse directement sur les mener
sur les régionales n'ont plus que jamais
sur les régionales on m'a posé des
questions mais c'était quel impact
généralement c'était quel impact sur la
présidentielle les candidats de vacances
alors c'est parce que ça fait pas
d'audience moi c'est pour ça que c'est
presque un coût pour les journalistes de
s'intéresser aux départementales kobori
medal d'abord est trop gros v6 attendait
suivez le raisonnement juste que je
voudrais vous en convaincre et à travers
vous notre public
si ça faisait de l'audience il y aurait
au moins un média qui s'en serait rendu
compte en ayant fait un sujet un micro
sujet dessus à partir du moment où vous
voyez que ça fait de l'audience
même si c'est pouvant table e manche et
en de préparer le sujet vous allez le
faire vous allez faire une meilleure
audience que votre concurrent en tant
que média c'est donc pour moi la preuve
que c'est le public qui s'en fout c'est
pas les médias qui veulent pas en parler
[Musique]